President Trump is refusing to tone down
his attacks on the late Senator John
McCain despite growing pushback from
fellow Republicans in a five minute rant
the president criticized the Arizona
Republican during a speech at an Ohio
military tank factory yesterday mr.
Trump said he never got to thank you for
McCain's funerals is so hard to read his
comments were met by silence from the
audience which included many military
veterans Republican Georgia senator
Johnny Isakson calls the president's
recent attacks deplorable Paula Reed is
at the White House once again here we
are Paula and all I can think about is
the McCain family good morning good
morning well the president says his
deepest grievance against the late
senator was his vote against a signature
Trump campaign promise to repeal
Obamacare and as the president gears up
for a grueling 2020 campaign he's trying
very hard to convince voters that John
McCain is the reason he wasn't able to
deliver on his promise of better
healthcare so I have to be honest I've
never liked him which President Trump
once again blasted the late Senator John
McCain for thwarting a Republican effort
to repeal Obamacare he said two hours
before he was voting to repeal and
replace and he went to thumbs down badly
hurting the Republican Party badly
hurting our nation attacking a decorated
veteran seems an odd choice when
speaking at a plant that makes military
tanks
the patriotic crowd which included many
veterans cheered the president's arrival
but fell silent when the president dove
into petty grievances complaining he was
never properly thanked for McCain's
funeral I gave him the kind of funeral
that he wanted which as president I had
to approve I don't care about this I
didn't get thank you that's okay we sent
him on the way but I wasn't a fan of
John McCain's McCain carefully planned
his funeral before he died last year but
mr. Trump was conspicuously not invited
and spent the day golfing and tweeting
this is a new bizarre low
several months later Megan McCain is
still defending her father you would
think it was hilarious that our
president was so jealous of him and he
was dominating the news cycle and death
as well and in the wake of these recent
attacks some Republicans are telling the
president to knock it off including
Senator Lindsey Graham I don't like it
when he says things about my friend John
McCain the President appears unmoved he
seems to relish McCain as a foil someone
who embodies the Washington
establishment and was willing to
compromise with Democrats but it's
unclear how this approach will resonate
with his base David Paula thank you